on vient de le voir les français sont de
plus en plus sensibles aux énergies
renouvelables on pense bien sûr au
solaire à l'éolien ou au bois
mais il ya aussi la force qui vient des
vagues là où il représente en effet un
formidable réservoir d'énergie et des
chercheurs français met au point un
système qui permettrait d'en exploiter
une partie reportage annonce nicolas
chateauneuf jean francois monier des
vagues et du vent
depuis qu'il sillonne les océans les
hommes sont gênés par la houle
mais elle pourrait bientôt se faire
pardonner en leur fournissant un peu
d'électricité
le secret c'est ce drôle d'engin
flottant aux formes étranges baptisé ci
rêve
nous sommes à l'école centrale de nantes
ici se trouve la plus grande piscine à
vagues de france un outil ultra
perfectionné au milieu du bassin
une maquette au 1 12e un prototype
capable de transformer en électricité
l'énergie des vagues
l'aboutissement de quatre années de
recherche
en fait il faut vraiment faire des
choses se soient très robuste qui puisse
tenir à la mer pendant très longtemps et
en fait c'est ça qui complique
énormément les cheveux au milieu des
vagues artificielles le comportement de
la maquette et étudier la loupe son
coeur est occupé par un grand pendule
qui oscille au gré des vagues
grâce à un système ingénieux le
mouvement est amplifié optimisée et
génère un courant électrique dans trois
ans le premier exemplaire de 25 mètres
de long sera mis à l'eau il devra
fournir de l'énergie à 200 foyers à
terme des milliers d'unités pourrait
voir le jour
on va aller chercher une certaine
profondeur pour aller installer ces
machines profondeur d'eau de l'ordre de
30 à 40 mètres ce qui fait qu'elles sont
quand même à une dizaine de kilomètres
des côtes
elles sont totalement invisibles c'est
une technologie qui est totalement
invisible du rivage d'autres pays sont
intéressés l'angleterre tests déjà en
mer son propre prototype là où il génère
en effet une énergie immense
équivalentes à celles produites sur
terre par toutes les centrales
électriques